hola este es el vídeo de química
esencial número 45 y hablaremos de la
clasificación de los catalizadores o
mejor dicho de los tres tipos de
catalizadores que generalmente usamos a
los catalizadores son muy importantes en
la fabricación en la refinación y de
hecho son muy importantes en la vida y
los podemos clasificar en tres tipos
existen catalizadores ha sido base como
por ejemplo el ácido sulfúrico
también tenemos catalizadores
superficiales que son como el
convertidor catalítico de un coche que
puede tomar el monóxido de carbono un
gas muy peligroso y convertirlo en
dióxido de carbono y finalmente tenemos
a las enzimas que son otro grupo de
catalizadores que principalmente
participan en todas las reacciones
químicas que ocurren en el cuerpo humano
entonces podemos clasificar a los
catalizadores en tres tipos
catalizadores ácido base superficiales
encimas ahora cómo funciona un
catalizador ácido base bueno este tipo
de catalizadores agregan o quitan un
protón a un reactivo y eso provoca que
se acelere la reacción mientras que un
catalizador superficial generalmente
está hecho de metal y si podemos
aumentar el área de contacto superficial
funcionará aún mejor lo que hacen este
tipo de catalizadores es incrementar el
número de colisiones exitosas que
ocurren en una reacción y también pueden
crear nuevos intermediarios de reacción
o nuevos pasos en el mecanismo de la
reacción y finalmente tenemos a las
enzimas que son catalizadores biológicos
estos catalizadores también pueden
producir nuevos intermediarios de
reacción o simplemente pueden cubrir a
una molécula y disminuir su energía de
activación entonces empecemos con los
catalizadores ácido base recuerden estos
catalizadores le agregan o le quitan
a alguno de los reactivos aquí tenemos
un ejemplo de una reacción catalizada
por un catalizador ácido base miren aquí
tenemos iso butano y propano que los
podemos encontrar en la gasolina y este
es un paso de refinación en el que se
produce hizo octano se produce otro
hidrocarburo y si alguna vez han ido a
ponerle gasolina a su coche y se han
dado cuenta de que existen diferentes
niveles de octano bueno eso se refiere
al porcentaje de octano o mejor dicho de
hizo octano que tiene en particular esa
gasolina y miren entre mayor sea el
número bueno no es que nos dé más
energía pero sí ayuda a que la
combustión en nuestro motor sea mucho
mejor y si usamos gasolina con un
porcentaje de hizo octano muy bajo
podrían experimentar una especie de
golpeteo en su motor porque ese tipo de
gasolina funciona mejor para un motor
dice entonces regresando a los
catalizadores cuál es la función del
ácido sulfúrico
el ácido sulfúrico donará un protón
protón al propano y así podemos formar
aliso octano que de otra manera no se
formaría por sí solo ahora veamos cómo
funciona un catalizador superficial
bueno los catalizadores superficiales
están hechos de metal y por ejemplo si
tenemos un gran pedazo de metal los
electrones se compartirán en una nube
electrónica deslocalizada alrededor de
todos los átomos pero si nos acercamos
más a la superficie de ese metal
encontraremos que hay electrones de sap
área dos sitios activos en la superficie
de ese metal y eso es lo que permite que
ocurra la catálisis de la reacción miren
en este caso tenemos hidrógeno gaseoso y
etileno y lo que ocurre es que se
adhieren a la superficie del catalizador
a ese proceso se le conoce como
absorción eso significa que no son
absorbidos por el metal solo
se adhieren a la superficie así están
compartiendo y moviendo los electrones
de un lugar a otro y al final bueno en
este caso los átomos de hidrógeno se
pueden mover por la superficie y será
más fácil que ocurra una colisión
exitosa contra esa molécula entonces
para este ejemplo podemos catalizar la
reacción en la superficie y así será más
fácil producir etam y claro al aumentar
el área superficial por ejemplo si
hacemos un polvo metálico muy muy fino
podemos hacer que aumenten las
colisiones y un excelente ejemplo de un
proceso catalizado de esta forma es el
proceso de javer fritz jaber fue un
científico que es muy reconocido y que
creó este proceso en el que se usa
nitrógeno del aire para producir
amoniaco ahora en la vida las bacterias
pueden hacer esto pueden tomar nitrógeno
del aire y fijarlo al suelo pero sin el
proceso de jaber nosotros no podríamos
hacerlo
estima que un tercio de todas las
personas que hay en nuestro planeta
comen alimentos que se producen gracias
a este proceso un proceso en el que se
usan diferentes catalizadores y en el
que hay muchos contenedores y si
analizamos todos los pasos elementales
para esta reacción ocurre mucha
absorción de gases y de nitrógeno para
que al final podamos producir amoniaco y
miren este es el perfil de energía para
esa reacción y bueno finalmente tenemos
a los catalizadores biológicos las
enzimas que son catalizadores que
podemos encontrar en nuestro cuerpo un
buen ejemplo de esto es la enzima que se
encarga de la descomposición de la
sacarosa la sacarosa es simplemente
azúcar común y si analizamos la molécula
podemos ver que hay dos moléculas unidas
vamos a representar las así entonces una
enzima a la que conocemos como sacar asa
agarra a la sacarosa y la descompone en
sus dos monosacáridos
así que todo en nuestro cuerpo es
controlado a través de enzimas
catalizadores como esta y si tienen
problemas para digerir lactosa es porque
no tienen suficiente lactasa la enzima
que se encarga de descomponer a la
lactosa por eso la forma en la que
controlamos todo en nuestro cuerpo es
con estos catalizadores biológicos que
están hechos de proteínas entonces
aprendieron a explicar los cambios en
las reacciones derivadas por
catalizadores ha sido base recuerden es
cuando se transfiere un protón también
están los catalizadores superficiales
que ayudan a que ocurran mejor las
colisiones o las enzimas que son
catalizadores biológicos espero que les
sirva